[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday
September 27th have some bad news
my throat is starting to get kind of raw
I'm sinus headache and my nose said any
kind of trippy so I think that I'm
getting sick also it hurts to speak but
unfortunately this whole thing is about
speaking text less without text meaning
speaking only I guess actually it could
be like she raised I could tell you
what's going on but with my hands
that's right I have a deadline and I'm
freaking out about it the good news is
that the person we have the deadline for
has given me a punishment for not
meeting my deadline which I haven't not
yet meant the deadline but I think I'm
gonna do the punishment just in case the
punishment for not meeting my deadline
is to compose a thesis on who I would
rather fight Helen Hunt in an
after-school special on PCP or the new
Bionic Woman before she adjusts to her
implants its television show on NBC
apparently I went to watch it online
which I'm sure has contributed to my
delinquency as far as the deadline goes
but I did it nonetheless because I'm
sick and I feel bad I have a cloudy cold
brain anyway so it's hard to write and I
have to be witty and being what he is
hard when you have cloudy cold brain PCP
has been shown to a lot of people to
unleash a great deal of strength this
generally thought was being beyond the
physical norm
while the bionic woman has been in some
way enhanced by something that does not
been kid not as far as I can tell exists
possibly nanobots
I don't know biologically doesn't make
any sense at all to me but she has been
enhanced and she seemed to be much
stronger than I think Helen Hunt would
be on PCP now that is one hazard that I
think would be roughly equal but the
Bionic Woman and Helen Hunt on PCP and
that is the danger of being hurled upon
both adjusting to Bionic implants and
PCP have been known to cause a great
deal of nausea and so in that case if I
could have gone with one that wasn't
gonna puke on me I would have gone with
that one but since they're both probably
gonna puke on me I'll have to make my
decision based on other criteria now
Wyatt unintelligence me to base my
opinion on how much I'm going to get the
crap beat out of me but frankly seeing
Helen Hunt down there in the schoolyard
dirt thrashing around in the broken
glass there's something different about
that then being flipped onto my head by
a nauseated confused young orphan I
believe that the best outcome of either
fight would be me consoling the young
woman on the ground as they cried
through their confusion and
disorientation and based on what I've
seen the Bionic Woman
I would rather comfort Helen Hunt what
can I say she makes my heart do
acrobatic stunts she faces the brunt of
the twister of my burning want Helen
Hunt
mad about her so how many minds too much
this is going to be a little bit of a
short video because I have to go back to
writing and my
Hertz hopefully I will be feeling better
soon especially before Wednesday because
I would really a tap to sing along with
this voice but we will have to wait and
see John I will see you tomorrow